new this morning you better look out  below our City's newest professional  sports team the desert dogs they're  gearing up for their first home game and  they're doing it in Vegas fashion yeah  they're a professional lacrosse team we  should point out midfielder Connor  cursed he attempted the world's highest  lacrosse shot but first well he had to  get to the top of the Strat  oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah  oh  [Applause]  Las Vegas desert dogs take on Panthers  City out of Fort Worth in their first  ever game Friday night Michelob Ultra  Arena it begins at seven tickets are  still on sale you think he'll be that  excited when he scores a real goal oh  yeah they better be now the party has  been set